[Música]
de esta pandemia han pensado en los
procesos contras y bueno sabemos que ha
causado graves daños económicos en costa
rica alrededor de 200.000 personas se
encuentran desempleados pero a pesar de
todo esto ahora podemos ver la
naturaleza de una forma distinta
yo crecí en miramar de puntarenas una
comunidad rural a 20 minutos de la playa
y dentro de la montaña en donde podía
ver aves con pericos y tucanes desde mi
casa además existe una diversidad de
microclimas hermosa dentro de un país
naturalmente único costa rica
en mi familia por más de 60 años se han
cuidado en los plantas es que tenemos
muchísimas plantas por lo que para mí es
totalmente normal vivir rodeada de
naturaleza de aves de plantas de hecho
mi hogar es conocido por ser la casa de
las plantas e incluso tomaron cuenta con
punto de referencia para dar una
dirección
y es ahora que el ser la chica de las
plantas es lo que me lleva a estar hoy
acá frente a ustedes para hablarles
desde mi experiencia en temas
ambientales en donde desde apoyar
campañas de reforestación y limpiezas en
mi comunidad hasta estar en espacios de
toma de decisiones y defender acuerdos
regionales
fue así que crecí pensando que todos los
hogares eran como el mío rodeados de
naturaleza de aves de plantas pero fue
hasta que salí a la ciudad que me di
cuenta que lo normal para muchísimas
personas es vivir rodeado de concreto y
muchísimo tránsito
es justamente ahora que estamos en esta
cuarentena en este encierro de estas
cuatro paredes que me doy cuenta de lo
vital que es vivir rodeado de naturaleza
porque no me imagino cómo sería medida
si está rodeada de de estas plantas y
sin poder salir a respirar aire puro
afuera
han visto este nuevo fenómeno en donde
ahora muchas personas están haciendo
cosas que antes no hacían salir a
caminar a hacer ejercicio a correr a
andar en bici
o el caso del típico vecino que antes no
hacía nada de ejercicio y ahora lo hace
ahora que hay un cuento hay que
y disfrutar de estos pequeños momentos
son las grandes cosas de la vida antes
pensaban que eran las pequeñas cosas de
la vida sin embargo esos momentos en los
que disfrutamos la vida son claves
gracias a este ambiente que crecí me
interesé por trabajar
y dejar una huella verde en cada lugar
prende pasar
el gusto que haya tenido que llegar una
pandemia para darnos cuenta cuánto bien
nos hace estar y convivir con la
naturaleza
cuántos de nosotros en este encierro no
vamos todo por estar cerca de una playa
una montaña o dentro de un bosque
porque antes de esta situación nos
preguntábamos cuánta naturaleza nos
rodeaba
yo uso ahora me doy cuenta lo vital y lo
importante que es vivir de la naturaleza
y de que ésta realmente es un privilegio
y no se le cuida ni se le valora como
debería fue gracias a que por fuerza
mayor gran parte del planeta tuvo que
permanecer en casa durante algunos meses
y justo ahora podemos ver con un ejemplo
más claro como la naturaleza se apropia
a los espacios que ya antes le
pertenecían podemos ver en varios países
en las ciudades en donde los animales
regresan a las calles y se encuentran en
las calles un hecho casi insólito
y para no ir más allá de nuestras
fronteras el limón los manatíes nadan
libremente
también a nivel mundial se ha comprobado
cómo han disminuido las emisiones y
concentración de carbono nuevamente para
no ir más allá de nuestras fronteras en
costa rica la universidad nacional
realizó un estudio en donde comprueba
que la concentración de nitrógeno
en la gran área metropolitana de marzo a
abril del presente año tuvo una
reducción entre un 28 y un 52% en
comparación al año anterior esto gracias
a las restricciones durante la pandemia
toda esta evidencia nos demuestra que el
planeta puede recuperarse si realizamos
un cambio en nuestro día a día
es el momento preciso para darnos cuenta
que no podemos regresar a ese pasado
ante la pandemia en donde vivíamos con
mucho tráfico consumo excesivo y
vivíamos en piloto automático sin ver lo
que estaba a nuestro alrededor
han surgido durante esta pandemia
grandes iniciativas que le permiten dar
al planeta un respiro como son es un
grupo que cree que en facebook en donde
las personas pueden intercambiar objetos
alimentos y servicios y que de alguna u
otra forma esto ha reactivado su
economía
también el teletrabajo que si bien antes
muchas empresas ya lo implementado otras
lo implementaron de forma obligatoria y
ahora oficial por los beneficios que
éste trae
y bueno sin duda alguna la venta de ropa
ha disminuido que desde nosotros nos
dimos cuenta de que podíamos sobrevivir
con siete con sólo siete prendas de ropa
porque incluso con menos ya que en una
videollamada sin cámara podemos estar
solo con la pijama
nos hemos detenido a pensar cuánto
impacto tiene nuestro estilo de vida en
la naturaleza
es lamentable que haya tenido que ser
gracias a esta pandemia en donde veamos
con un ejemplo más claro como nuestras
acciones repercuten en la naturaleza
está la primera crisis mundial que vive
en nuestra generación y espero que ésta
nos haya sacudió de tal forma que nos
haya hecho reaccionar para que veamos y
nos demos cuenta de que la manera en la
que vivíamos antes era totalmente
insostenible
hemos visto a miles de jóvenes en las
calles realizando huelgas por la
injusticia climática incidiendo
políticamente trabajando día con día por
mejorar nuestro entorno y preservar la
naturaleza esto lo hacemos porque nos
preocupa nuestro futuro y la crisis
climática que ya es una realidad en
muchos países
además enfrentamos el reto de las
migraciones por motivos ambientales que
si bien no es algo que vemos a diario en
el noticiero es una realidad para
muchísimas personas y a pesar de que
estos no sean totalmente responsables
del cambio climático
estas son las más afectadas una de las
primeras condiciones de la felicidad es
que el vínculo entre la naturaleza y el
hombre no se rompa esto lo decía el
escritor ruso león tolstoi quien fue uno
de los escritores más importantes para
la literatura mundial durante el siglo
19 y principios del siglo 20
además nuevamente para no ir más allá de
nuestras fronteras dentro de la
cosmovisión indígena la pachamama la
madre tierra el medio ambiente significa
toda la riva podemos ver que ha sido una
relación predicha desde hace siglos y
aún nos queda un largo camino por
recorrer para lograr una sociedad en
armonía con la naturaleza sin embargo
aún no es demasiado tarde ya que justo
ahora que nos encontramos dentro de
nuestras casas tenemos la oportunidad de
cuestionarnos sobre la relación que
tenemos con la naturaleza de reconocer
de reflexionar y de actuar pero sobre
todo de reinventarnos
me imagino que durante esta pandemia has
utilizado menos el cargo y bueno te
invito a probar cosas nuevas que bien
tal vez no estemos acostumbrados pero
les aseguro de que valdrá la pena
bueno sabemos que la mayoría está dentro
de la casa entonces qué puedo hacer yo
si soy desde mi casa desde realizar una
compostera para el abono de las plantas
en mi casa sin necesidad de tener un
terreno con un recipiente reciclar todos
los desechos
consumir menos carne desenchufar los
aparatos electrónicos
o es simple importante hecho de cerrar
la llave cuando no la estamos utilizando
de utilizar el agua sólo para lo
necesario y si muchos nos llamarán locos
o se burlen de lo que hacemos pero les
aseguro de que a ninguno de nosotros les
gustaría tener que llegar a guerras por
agua y oxígeno es una idea desenfrenada
pero si vamos seguimos a este paso
estamos muy cerca de llegar a ello
aún estamos a tiempo de actuar y
cuestionar y cambiar nuestro futuro que
les parece si cada uno de nosotros se
compromete a realizar una pequeña acción
cada día a favor del planeta a cambiar
nuestros hábitos y así reconectar nos
por con la naturaleza
[Música]